et bien moi le reportage que je rêve de
réaliser depuis fort longtemps
c'est une série d'entrevues avec
d'anciens présidents américains bien sûr
des présidents qui sont encore vivants
comme barack obama jimmy carter george
bush et connaître leur vision leur
vision du monde et aussi leur vision de
la présidence comment ils ont vécu ces
années intenses de leur vie avec du
recul ce qu'est ce qu'ils auraient fait
différemment et aussi les questionner
sur l'actuelle présidente somme qui est
vraiment une présidence atypique mais je
pense que ce serait une façon de en
interviewant les anciens présidents de
présenter une perspective au public
différentes sur la présidence américaine
ces difficultés et la façon dont ces
président s'en sont sortis et la façon
qu'ils ont vécu leur présidence une des
grandes frustrations des correspondants
à l'étranger d'avoir parfois
l'impression de ne jamais vraiment
savoir ce qui se passe derrière les
portes closes dans les milieux
diplomatiques par exemple dans les
sphères du pouvoir et donc un de mes
rêves c'est de pouvoir faire un
reportage un peu en coulisse suivre
quelqu'un comme par exemple le président
français emmanuel macron pour savoir
qu'est ce qu'il pense en privé par
exemple de quelqu'un comme dans notre
chemin
malheureusement ça va très probablement
rester dans l'ordre du fantasme parce
que pour des raisons évidentes
on va très probablement jamais nous
permettre de faire un tel reportage